- Earlier this season,
comedian Deon Cole was here
telling us about his movie
"The Harder They Fall,"
and while he wasn't at
the "SNL 40th Anniversary"
after-party, I'm assuming
my invitation as well
was misplaced at the printer,
cool, it's fine, I
didn't want to go anyway,
Deon and I, we had better things to do,
but he did have lots to say
about some other "SNL" legends.
So watch this.
So you're back to traveling
a bit for your stand-ups.
So is that exciting?
Are you a good traveler?
- Yeah, I mean, yeah, I mean, definitely.
We out hitting the road
again, doing our shows
and stuff and you know.
- That's cool.
- I'm a decent traveler.
I travel as light as possible though.
That's, see, that's what's
wrong with a lot of people,
when you travel, you take
too many what if clothes,
(audience laughing)
and you know you're not gonna
wear them what if clothes.
You know you not.
- This is true.
- You know, or you bring your fat clothes
and your skinny clothes.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- I just bring the fat ones.
- You just bring the?
(Deon laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
- I just don't even dream big.
I'm just like, I'm bringing the cozies.
- Yeah, I bring all my big clothes and if
I do get skinny, then I go shopping.
- That's what you
deserve for being skinny.
That's motivating.
- That's what you deserve.
(audience applauding)
if you get skinny, your reward is to shop.
- I like this.
- And that's what I say,
yeah, so that's what I do.
I make sure I roll up all
my clothes so everything
get in there, but there's
no in between clothes.
Either I look bummy or I'm super clean.
That's it.
- Me too.
(audience laughing)
Me too.
Who are these people
that, at like airports,
and they're literally like, I mean,
heeled out, like, full
on suit or like full,
it's all done, I'm like, where are you,
are you going directly
there when you land?
Like, like where are your comfy clothes?
- I think they get the, I
think the information is
if you in business class
or something like that,
you have to be dressed up or whatever.
That's how it used to be.
- They must look at me
like, how did you get here?
(audience laughing)
I'm usually in like comfy travel wear.
Anyway, I'm not trying to impress anyone.
So, and I'm like, do
you think you're going
to meet them on the plane?
All right, cool.
Do you ever ask other comedians,
like for their input, like on your jokes?
- Yeah, I mean some, well
I don't ask for my input,
but if we think of
something at the same time,
we'll sit there and
goes, yo, you want that?
I can have that, or you can have that,
and then we go like that or whatever.
- [Kelly] It's like songwriters.
- But every blue moon I like, I was,
I would go like to a
comedian and ask them,
is this cool or not?
You know, like, I'll call up
Dave Chappelle and be like,
hey, let me know how you
feel about this joke.
He never calls back, but.
(audience laughing)
- Maybe that's how he felt.
- Yeah, yeah.
I call, I call up Chris Rock, hey.
Never calls back.
Sin, never calls back.
So I end up doing it my own self.
- [Kelly] I know, I love it.
- Yeah, either it work or it don't work.
- That's how you find out.
It lands or it doesn't.
So wait, so wait, have
you had a chance to meet?
I know you, they won't answer your calls,
apparently any of those comedians,
but like have you had a chance to meet?
- Hey Sinbad, call me back, all right?
If you can, Sinbad.
- But any of your idols,
have you been able to like,
I don't know, hang with them at all, or.
- Man, yeah.
Man, a lot of 'em.
I just, man, Eddie Murphy.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- Man, yeah.
Give it up for Eddie.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- [Deon] Yeah, I was with Eddie.
- [Kelly] He's one of my faves.
- I remember when
"Dreamgirls" was happening,
I was leaving this event and the,
no, I was coming to the
event and he was leaving
and I was like, oh my God, it's Eddie,
and I was standing behind
him and I just leaned over,
and I said, hey, how you doing?
I know you don't know
me, but I'm gonna work
with you one day, and he just
looked at me and was like.
- He was like, stage five clinger.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause I
was leaning, had that
Michael Jackson lean too, I was like,
(audience laughing)
hey I know you don't know me but I'm going
to be working with him
one day, I know that.
- And it's not meant to be creepy at all.
- Yeah, yeah, but then here we
are later, I was at a party,
a Netflix party, and he came up to me
and told me he enjoyed my work and.
- Did he remember that, the other time?
- No, he did not, he just came up to me.
He was like, man, I'm a fan of your work,
and I couldn't believe it,
and yeah.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And, and also now I'm
working with him too so.
- That's so cool.
(audience applauding)
I love that.
I love when you meet people
you love and they're cool.
- Yeah, exactly.
He's super cool.
He's like super cool, and he has
a lot of knowledge too, man.
Like, he was telling me
about "Trading Places,"
the amount of money he made
on that, on "Trading Places."
- Yeah, I love that you were like.
- I was like this.
I would have made "Trading Places."
- [Kelly] Like for a third of that.
- Oh, no, it was nothing.
- Oh, I thought you were
saying you were brag,
'cause he was like, I made a ton of money.
- No, that was something they would have
paid me to pay, to do "Trading Spaces."
- Oh my gosh.
- No, they gave him like
nothing really for that.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- Yeah, that's what he told me.
He told me that one time, yeah.
- That's why the next
time around you go, nope.
- Yeah, but the next
time he made up for that.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I would
have too if I were him.
- I'm quite sure, yeah, yeah.
That's how you gotta do.
- I thought you were saying,
yeah, he told me how much money
you made, and I was like,
that's kind of weird.
- [Deon] No.
(Deon laughing)
- I banked on this one job,
like, just to rub it in.
So wait, do you remember how
you reacted when you first
had your first fan
experience with someone,
like really loving you?
- Yeah, it scared me.
- [Kelly] What, what?
- Because I was in Chicago
doing a whole bunch
of goofy stuff, man, and
I was at the gas station.
I used to smoke cigarettes.
I was going to get some
cigarettes and this dude,
I had been doing comedy maybe
two months and this dude
pulled up and was like,
Hey Deon, and I ran.
(audience laughing)
- Did you owe someone money, like what?
- I just, I was running and
I heard him in the district
go, you funnier than a (bleep).
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh, that's
your first experience.
- And I was like, I start
slowing down like, thank you.